welcome to build with google cloud where
we build
things reference architectures that can
help you make your google cloud journey
a little bit easier in this episode we
are going to see how you can build a
tiny bank on google cloud
[Music]
so you are an organization that wants to
either build new or modernize
traditional banking products and
solutions where do you get started well
stay with me to find out i'm priyanka
vergaria developer advocate here at
google cloud and today let's see what
your options are to build a modern
digital banking platform on google cloud
are you ready
let's go
[Music]
banks were born to help us manage our
money over the years the value provided
by the bank has expanded from checking
savings and personal loans with money
transfer solutions and bill pays and
rewards
sadly these solutions feel disconnected
even today
it is time for a simpler experience with
deeper integrations into the bank and
each aspect of our lives so we don't
have to carry so many different apps on
our phones for utility credit cards and
to manage our budget
another example is it is a common
practice for hotels and airlines to
leverage banks to create their own
credit cards we should see a future
where more services can be offered via
banking as a service model which is
modular cloud native digital bank
architecture that offers financial
products and services via apis and
microservices
why modular well because value-added
services on digital platforms enable the
bank to quickly adapt to emerging
markets and demands by measuring success
and outcomes and can allow them to build
new products in a matter of days and not
months or years
now another example here is banks are
able to easily provide e-commerce
retailers with a value-added service
that offers instant loans or buy now pay
later checkout options on their websites
and the only way this is possible is
with a modular architecture
so
now that we know that we need a modular
architecture let's see what it takes to
get there
here are some of the api products that
are central to embedded finance which
refers to core banking services which
includes opening an account or checking
balance and making payments but managing
these api products and services has
increased in scale cost and complexity
because the legacy architecture was a
one-on-one mapping between core banking
system and banking front-end such as the
website
the modern banking as a service model
requires one-to-many mapping of the core
banking microservices with an api layer
this new platform enables business
transformation by embedding and
integrating core capabilities securely
with as many new systems and partners as
needed such as airlines utilities
transportations and telcos i've already
dropped some hints about how you could
start to build this modern banking as a
service platform would you like to take
a shot at some of the components that
you can start with share with me in the
comments below okay so now that we know
what problem we are solving when it
comes to modernizing retail banking
let's see how we solve it
time to dive into the high level
components that we need
a modern digital bank comprises of
multiple business functions and
capabilities these logical components
can be organized into a few high level
categories let's consider a fictitious
financial institution symbol bank
it has to have services across various
channels to serve the external customers
these could include applications that
directly serve the customers the
payments the operations services for
onboarding management servicing and then
the partner services
then comes the integration services
which act as the interoperability and
connectivity layer for all the bank
services and applications
essentially the technology glue that
brings the core platform data and
various applications together to
orchestrate and provide a business
function for the bank to its users
then there are the data applications and
platform which include the various data
pipelines streaming processing
governance and data warehousing for
applications and services
the enterprise application services make
up the enterprise back office services
that keep the business operating and
compliant well these include various
foundational components of the bank like
finance and treasury financial erp the
governance risk and control the
regulatory reporting and audit and
compliance
now core application services are theos
core services and applications and data
that are required for a bank to offer
products and services to their customers
these include the core banking data
models for sensitive customer
information transactions products and
things like that as well as all the
processing and persistence of that data
now
core services include card management
payments collections and credit and
fraud risks then there are the
infrastructure operations and security
components that apply to all functional
aspects of the bank's capabilities these
are considered foundational components
to ensure the bank's customer data
integrity and privacy with appropriate
controls and policies that adhere to the
bank's internal controls and government
regulations now that we know what
capabilities a bank needs or offers we
are ready to dive into the architecture
to make this work well in this part of
the video we are going to look at each
of the segments of the retail banking
one by one from channel services
integration services data applications
and platforms
enterprise application services
core application services
and infrastructure security and
operations
channel services include services for
customer channels such as banking and
customer services using contact center
ai and messaging
transaction channels such as credit and
debit payments using google pay and
partner channels which is connecting
with open banking apis and other
marketplaces using apigee api gateway
now these services power the customer
applications such as the ones needed for
operations
onboarding management servicing the
customer showing customers the right ads
sales marketing and loyalty apps
then you have the integration layer
which comprises the api connectors on
apigee api management these connectors
take the real time and batch
unstructured and structured data and
then pass it on to the data science
layer for further analysis and creating
unique user experiences like
personalized recommendations and
propensity models or preventing
financial crime with fraud prediction
and anomaly detection with vertex ai
platform you can also run high
performance computing workloads using
tensor gpus
within vertex ai
in addition vertex ai streamlines the
iml pipelines and provides explainable
ai outputs and model governance
now event and transformation hub also
ingests the batch data through cloud
storage and real-time data through pub
sub messaging service and passes it on
to data flow for transformation and
orchestration
the process data is then sent to
serverless data warehouse bigquery and
metadata that is stored in cloud storage
which is a data lake
other teams and applications can then
access this data through a unified data
management catalog dataplex
as you can see the data platform enables
the bank to securely process and store
sensitive customer data while enriching
with additional data sets to gain a
better understanding of their customers
and products
then comes the enterprise application
services that make up the back office
services which keep the business
operating and compliant
these include various foundational
components of the bank like finance and
treasury financial erp
visualizations regulatory reporting
audits compliance governance risk and
control
we query the data with bigquery and then
use it to generate visualizations in
looker
core application services are the core
services that are required for a bank to
offer its products and services to the
customers now these services are
typically deployed as micro services on
kubernetes engine with transaction
products and customer data on cloud
spanner event driven micro services
communicate with each other using cloud
pubs up
additional core services include card
management and payments and collections
and credit and fraud risk
then there are the core security and
operational components that apply to all
the functional aspects of the bank's
capabilities now these services include
identity and access management for
authentication and authorization
standards data locality encryption and
key management data anonymization and
tokenization along with system network
and application logs for access
transparency and monitoring incidents
and slas
i know i know that was a lot but don't
worry i've linked a sample application
code for you that you can run as your
own bank on google cloud click and learn
how it works and don't forget to share
how it went for you we just looked at a
reference architecture to build a
digital banking platform on google cloud
the different components and google
cloud services that you can use to build
those components or augment them
wherever you start it'll be a success
and great start to gain agility in
launching new features innovation and
improving customer experience while
keeping the data safe and using it to
gain insights
now it's your turn go build a tiny
digital bank using the documentation and
full sample code repository linked below
if you liked this video then i encourage
you to let me know by clicking on the
like and subscribe buttons oh and if you
want to see me build a specific
architecture in this series let me know
in the comments below i cannot wait to
build more stuff with you
[Music]
you